[Musique]
avec henri boucher qui est membre de
cette association les p'tits cure
d'étoilés la plus d'un se disent je ne
sais pas trop ce que c'est ça vous parle
les petits cueillir des toiles normale
n'avait jamais entendu parler
maintenant qu'elle est bien gêné non
ouais qu'est ce que c'est que cette
association
alors si tu ne cesses une association
qui a été qui a été imaginé créé par des
scientifiques des planétologues des
cosmochimistes ou là attention attention
parce que c'est plus docile là vous
savez le vendredi c'est donc à ce mot
not peut-être alors y en a on a on a
happy rainurés qui a été l initiateur
s'initie 7 cette association est notre
part actuelle c'est une spa du toit
scientifique quoi que j'en sois mcg jean
pierre darroussin d'accord on sait
d'autre part d'associations et j'espère
qu'un jour et j'espère qu'un jour il
viendra
il viendra avec moi
une animation des petits coeurs des
toiles vous savez avant qu'on arrive sur
ces animations
moi je fais le pari là sur france 3 ce
vendredi de vous dire les yeux dans les
yeux si vous avez jean pierre darroussin
vous revenez pour qu'on puisse ensemble
avec jean-pierre justement refaire
découvrir les petits cueilleurs des
toiles renvoie l'image là quelques
quelque chose enfin quelques je suis
arrivé ce matin serbe
n'oubliez surtout pas les liens des
quelques peluches voilà merci quelques
peluches qui sont en premier plan voici
un casque de spationautes
alors qu'est ce que vous faites de tout
ça c'est pour vos animations qu'est ce
que c'est que ces émissions alors on
fait des animations dans les hôpitaux
dans les services de pédiatrie auprès
des enfants hospitalisés
et pour pour le redonner le sourire pour
l'offre pour l'heureux améliorer leur
quotidien au milieu hospitalier qui est
pas toujours très agréables
c'est ce qu'on voit là la photo voici la
voilà avec un de vos camarades
le casque de spationautes effectivement
on comprend connu dans un hôpital pour
enfants
c'est toujours dans les services
pédiatriques oui oui et donc la ccsa
commencé dans les hôpitaux parisiens
puisque évidemment l'association a été
créée d'abord par des parisiens donc on
sait ça s'est ensuite étendu sur des
grandes villes comme nancy bordeaux lyon
voilà ressentent
et toulouse ce qui est important c'est
que ça commence aussi chez des voisins
ont raconté ces vous vous commencez avec
dijon mais j'ai entendu dire que
besançon était déjà dans les rails et
que ça qu'on perd ses dents mais c'est
dans mes idées d'aller de me rapprocher
des services aux enfants hospitalisés de
besançon et ce n'est peut-être même
belfort-montbéliard et j'espère bien et
puis peut-être cana qui nous écoutent
vous savez régulièrement reçoit des gens
dans le domaine médical et je suis
certain convaincu que s'il nous regarde
il ya peut-être aussi des parents
d'enfants malades qui pourraient
suggérer cette association dans le
service pédiatrique parce que quand on
voit la halle et les enfants on imagine
que il ya plein de souvenirs dans votre
tête quel est votre plus beau souvenir
justement lors de ces animations à leur
joie
voici ma ça va être ma deuxième
animation j'en ai fait une
il ya tout un mois de septembre ici par
contre j'ai des retours d'expérience de
ce qu'ils ont en fait déjà plus
alors je sais par exemple que à l'un des
animateurs de la région parisienne
un jour une mère d'enfants a dit vous
êtes mieux que la morphine et saas et
voilà ça se passe de commentaire
ça se passe de commentaire moi je sais
que l'animation que j'avais fait ici on
avait un enfant qui on lui avait dit le
matin qu'on allait venir faire des dons
qu'on fait des animations autour du
système solaire
et de l'astronomie qu'on a vu douala et
et cet enfant qui est hospitalisée
depuis peut-être déjà une dizaine de
jours avait dit son intérêt sport je
peux y aller tout et voilà et à la fin
de notre animation il avait été
interviewé par nos confrères d'une radio
et il avait dit ouah c'est super j'ai
même un truc j'ai posé plein de
questions enfin bref voilà et et sa
maman qui était là avait dit c'est la
première fois que je vois sourire depuis
depuis t-il hospitalisé on a eu aussi un
autre enfant qui d'après ce que les
éducatrices m'avait dit tu étais de
vivre probablement à une forme d'autisme
enfin je suis passé pénalisé pour
produire ce qu'il avait mais toujours
est il que cet enfant là apparemment on
avait du mal à tenir en place pour trois
minutes quoi c'était compliqué et là
pendant plus d'une heure il est resté
captivé par tout ce qu'on a raconté
donc ça leur change vraiment il voulait
emmener en voyage voilà exactement c'est
ça on parle parfois dans la lune
carrément parce que on voit on voit dit
l'une au dessus on voit mars jupiter
vénus et c'est peut-être à l'image et
puis alors j'ai j'ai le sentiment que
vous jouez aussi les père noël parfois
parce que quand vous allez dans les
services pédiatriques auprès de ses
enfants pour faire ces animations
alors c'est pas déguisé c'est habillée
en cosmonaute parce que c'est pas des
déguisements sa combinaison peut pas le
trou aller sur la lune mais oui oui mais
surtout vous donner ces petites choses
là qu'est ce que c'est ça c'est un bout
d'une je disais tout à l'heure vous
décrochez les ans c'est pas un beau de
lune mais c'est une vraie météorite
c'est à dire c'est un caillou
extraterrestres qui a attiré sur terre
et
et quoi aux frais qu'on offre autant
dans nos freins un spécimen par enfant à
la fin notre animation donc ils
ressentiront d'hôpital avec ce petit
souvenir mais moi je dis félicitations
bravo coup de chapeau aux jeux parce que
vous en pensez mais moi je suis là je
suis pas bluffé par ce que ça existe
mais en tout cas je suis émerveillée par
ce que vous faites et j'ai envie de
saluer cette initiative l'association
les p'tits cueillir des toiles faire
découvrir le monde de l'espace de
l'astronomie et de la géologie aux
enfants malades afin d'améliorer leur
quotidien pour mieux vivre leur
hospitalisation
c'est finalement le but de ces petits
cueillir des toiles rendez vous sur le
net pour en savoir plus petits clients
des toiles point frp apostrophe un petit
cueillant de toile